hello everyone and don't worry i'm not
gonna scare you in 4k in every video but
i'm probably willing most of them uh so
we are in game four magnus is leading
the game
the match and hikaru now needs a win to
bounce back and maybe
uh force uh well not force anything but
he needs to finish the second
the first uh day uh in a tie so he can
look for chances uh tomorrow so if he
loses this one or draws this one
uh magnus wins the first match so
without further ado let's check it out
it's
another another very interesting game so
hikaru this time with the white pieces
first game we're showing where hikaru
has white because uh
we showed the first game then we skipped
the second one it was a fairly quick
draw
then magnus won the third one and now
we're showing the fourth one so let's
see
what happens here hikaru opens with d4
uh and magnus goes for d5 we have c for
c6 at the slop defense knight to f3
we have knight to f6 and now e3
we have bishop to g4 pinning the knight
and now h3 and magnus gives up the
bishop for knight here we have captures
captures
and now e6 so you've given away your
light light square bishop
now you're gonna put your pawns on light
squares and then the dark square bishop
is free to roam
in between them so bishop to d3 and now
knight b to d7 so this has all been
played before uh many many times
we have castles by hikaru and bishop to
d6
we have knight to c3 and magnus castles
now we have rook to d1
and rook to e8 again adding more
pressure to the e5 square e5
is coming at some point we have queen
back to e2
uh and now comes queen to e7 uh we have
bishop to d2 and
now only now magnus captures on c4
and prepares e5 we have bishop captures
and now the immediate e5
uh we have captures on e5 queen captures
on e5 now threatening queen to h2
then king f1 queen to h1 will be
checkmate so
g3 stopping that weakening the king side
a little bit
and only now b5 striking uh on the queen
side attacking the light square bishop
bishop back to b3 and now there is one
game where knight to c5 was played but
here magnus plays a5
and it is already as of move 16 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how hikaru deals with this he goes
bishop back to c2
uh as well both bishop and knight are
about to be attacked so the the bishop
will be very nice here if you can get
rook to c1 maybe bishop to b1 then you
will be you will be okay
but here queen to e6 now this is uh
not a problem but it is a it is a very
good square for the queen
and you are attacking the h3 pawn so
hikaru defends it
and now a4 grabbing more space on the
queen side we have
a3 not allowing b4 and
now comes knight to e5 and this is a
very very active position for magnus and
he can be i think very
happy with what he achieved out of the
opening with the black pieces
uh concerning uh or rather regarding the
current situation of the match he only
needs to draw this game to win the first
match
uh and here you don't really have the uh
natural rook to c1 maybe just knight c4
attacks the b
pawn and you don't have anything better
than maybe rook back to b1
so it's you're going to have to work a
little bit harder to get all of your uh
pieces fully operational so bishop back
to b1 here
and now comes uh well uh you could go
here
knight to c4 like in the previous one
but now bishop to a2 would be a problem
so uh hence the bishop to b1 move so
here queen back to e7 by magnus and now
bishop back to e1 uh opening up the d
file for the rook with rook 8 d8 finally
bringing that last
big piece into the game and now bishop
to a2 this is a very nice
diagonal for this light square bishop we
have knight eat the d7
and now queen to c2 and now preparing
rook a to c1 and then at some point you
will try and apply pressure to the c
file with bishop to e5 and here uh rook
ate the c1 here hikaru could have
gone for something like knight captures
and b5 it's a super tricky line
uh the point is that uh once the knight
is captured bishop to b for traps the
queen
you you don't have anywhere to go with
the queen you can see that the bishop
pair is indeed fully operational here
problem is you don't really win the
queen because you can just give back the
piece and then
for example if it captures captures uh
we're gonna win
uh win back the piece here and then we
can just trade everything off
and we have this position where uh
hikaru would be
up upon and he would still enjoy the the
bishop
pair uh but it's uh you know hard to say
if he would be able to
to do anything more than that here
problem is if you go
after this this guy here then rook b1
attacks the bishop the bishop moves you
win another pawn
so you don't really win back the pawn so
it's possible and probably the best
hikaru had in this position but he
wanted to keep the pressure
rook 8 to c1 as he needs a win in this
game
and now magnus gave him a chance he
played knight
to c5 and now hikaru can take advantage
of this move but it's up to you to help
him so of course as usual
feel free to pause the video and help
hikaru while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
finding the strongest move and that is
most often
a move with the knight back and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's
knight the e2 and now you can see that
this is just
weird here the knight is under attack
and if you move the knight then
queen captures on c6 and then all of
these pawns fall
yes you do grab the b2 pawn but after
bishop to b4
again attacks the queen where is this
queen going you can play some like
queen to a7 but then rook 8 to b1 and
it's just a very very tough position to
play the bishop is under attack the b5
pawn is under attack
uh everything is uh just you know
hanging so
while this was definitely an option uh
here we have rook captures on d1
uh and now comes uh uh
sorry after knight to e2 we have rook
capture sunday one and now
rook captures on d1 and now queen to a7
so not allowing the bishop to be for to
come with a pin
on the queen on e7 so a queen to a7 here
and now comes rook the c1 by hikaru and
this was a
the moment where hikaru could have
seized the opportunity maybe a little
bit better
knight to d4 poses a lot of problems for
for black because the c6 pawn is under
attack
and if you try defending this for
example rook the c8 then knight f3 is
extremely strong how do you defend the
bishop
you have to move it and once you move it
uh for example ruby 8 now you play
knight to g5
and now it's just uh just a terrible
terrible position for for black
so uh maybe this could have been uh you
know a little bit better but he car went
rook a to c1 he applied pressure here
and now magnus just played knight to e6
and now there's a problem if you capture
here then bishop captures on v2 is
actually good
so here hikaru played f3 uh taking care
of all of these squares now you don't
have to worry about
magnus's knights there and not knight to
d5 so
you weaken the e3 square yeah let's
let's just grab that
and uh you could go after it with the
queen but
uh for example if queen captures an e3
then bishop to f2 is coming
and you know could be it could be
problematic to save this queen where
you could go to g5 or h6 but it looks uh
it looks very
very unnatural for example queen h6
you're gonna play f4
and it's uh it's maybe playable but
uh of course he's not uh interested in
playing something like this in a
must-win situation so instead
knights the d5 now going after this pawn
uh and nakam's queen captures and c6
grabbing the pawn
knight captures an e3 with check king h1
and now queen to b8 putting pressure on
the g3 pawn twice so
bishop to f2 attacking the knight here
and now comes bishop captures on b2 this
is what magnus goes for now the rook is
under attack
and hikaru has to go for it with bishop
captures an e3 bishop captures in c1
and now bishop captures in c1 again
here hikaru uh if
if queen captures and c1 had been played
it's also possible
but we have bishop captures on c1 and
now
we have rook to c8 and this is a problem
again
uh okay it doesn't really matter if the
queen captures or the bishop but and now
that the bishop captured
uh you have a very nice move here with
black
and that is not rook to see it with
magnus played but rather queen to see it
and it looks very counterintuitive
but chess usually works like that so
here i'm just going to show it because
it's super fun
queen the c8 is deadly here because
you don't really have a good move with
white if you trade queens
then rook the c2 is coming and even if
you capture for example an e6
uh hoping for a recapture black will
still play this
attack the knight if the knight moves
then the bishop hangs
this bishop is also hanging here so
let's say bishop f5
attacks the rook rook captures anitu and
yes you do have a bishop pair
for the uh for the rook but it's not
enough uh
bishop to f4 because you're threatening
rookie one check to win the bishop
so bishop to f4 let's say now comes b4
and now your passport is too strong
a3 you have to create some sort of a
barrier
uh the the bishop will not be able to
come to e5 so you're going to have to
play bishop to e4
a2 now you're going to stop queening but
it doesn't matter
just rookie one chuck king to g2 and now
a1 queen
and that's it captures captures and
black should be
black should be able to win this uh uh
you know after after some moves uh but
okay
after this um rook to see it or maybe
maybe it's possible to hold this i don't
know if this is a table based draw
not entirely familiar with this but
uh black black should be able to do it
especially especially
in a rapid game but okay after bishop
captures on c1
we have rook to c8 instead of queen to
c8 and now this
only helps white so here hikaru goes
queen to e4
and now queen to d6 by magnus now with
ideas of maybe shifting the queen over
to d1
uh and the problem is uh hikaru here has
three and a half minutes on the clock
whereas magnus has
47 seconds on the clock so hikaru has to
play something uh quickly to put more
pressure on magnets so here he goes
bishop to e3
he asks magnus are you maybe interested
in a nice juicy a3 pawn
however if magnus goes for this a3 pawn
then
bishop captures an e6 and then
everything you know that kind of falls
apart
so instead magnus goes queen to d1 check
uh here we have
knight to g1 blocking with the knight
back as one always should
and the queen to c2 now offering a queen
trade and then if the rook comes to the
second rank then it's going to be very
good for black
so here what you have to do is uh bishop
captures an e6 this is what you have to
play here
then we trade queens for example
captures captures and captures and then
you have this position with bishop and
knight against the rook
but now it's different because this will
not be happening we're going to play
bishop to d2 and
we're going to stop that and if you go
after the bishop just bishop can be
played to b4
and these pawns will no longer be an
issue if you play rook c4
go after this pawn it's not a problem
knight e2 yes you will win this but now
knight c3 attacks the rook and the pawn
rook has to defend it now you start
bringing the key into the game
and the white is okay here but after
queen to c2 we have queen to d5
instead by hikaru and here magnus played
only one more move and
uh well i'm not gonna tell you what
happened just yet but feel free to pause
the video here
and try and win this game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting
you know either of the two moves either
rook to d8
is what magnus played but also queen to
b2
is is very very strong uh magnus just
played rook to d8 and here he car
resigned problem is you don't have
anywhere
any square for the queen because the
bishop hangs here hikaru missed this
and i guess he was just trying to play
too much on magnus's time
and it was uh not enough so he had to
win this game at the bonds back in the
match to start for uh start
a new tomorrow but he lost the second
one as well or rather the fourth game
and now magnus wins the match
by by winning
two games game three and game four so
here like i said there's no move
once the queen moves or whatever you can
even grab a pawn just queen captures
here
and now you are down simply too much
material there's no plane there
there is a really no uh even uh
a chance of playing this you you could
for example grab here
uh but uh still it it will not be enough
the rook is simply too powerful you're
gonna play one move like h6 to create a
breeding room for the king
and you don't have to worry white has a
dark square bishop and uh
well you could play the song and maybe
try and accomplish something but
i think hikaru was just too disgusted at
himself at this point to even
to even try uh proving something here so
after magnus played rook to d8 uh
resigned and
magnus wins the match so that's
it for the coverage of day one hope you
guys enjoyed it and like i said uh sorry
about
uh everything being new and you know
it's i mean
uh we we i had had to relocate uh that's
how life works but i will uh you know
try to improve everything improve the
room uh get more stuff here uh
i i do understand that there's still
echo
in the in the audio so i will do my best
to fix that as soon as possible
uh maybe even for tomorrow we'll see how
it goes uh but yeah all in all
uh we should see improvements by by each
day
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank uh italbone
uh michael higgins seagrave gallery
colin lancaster
and dustin lackey for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
tomorrow checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day